Speaker 1: Our friends from the Good Liars have
done it again. Dave Room and Jason from The Good
Liars were at the NRA conference over the weekend.
They asked a guy in a Confederate flag shirt,
is he for slavery or is he against slavery? And
the guy didn't want to comment. Now, in my world,
if you don't say I'm against slavery, you
might be in favor of it, but I'll let you
guys be the judge of that. These are extremely
good videos that the guys have been doing.
This is Jason interviewing this guy. Guys
wearing a black Make America Great Again hat
and a keep flying Confederate flag shirts. The
topic is well, that connects to slavery. Are
you for or against slavery? And the
guy pleads the fifth on the easiest
question in the world. Take a look at this.
Speaker 6: Just keep it flying. Keep it fly. And
why do you want to keep it flying? Why do you want
it? Why would anybody want our race, our heritage?
Well, some people would say that that flag
symbolizes racism, it symbolizes slavery,
and they might have some valid points there.
That's their opinion, you know, and they welcome
their opinion if they want it. Are you are you
pro slavery or against slavery? I have no comment.
Speaker 1: No comment. Guys, he
is not going to weigh in on that
controversial venomous political issue.
Speaker 6: But thank you for the interview.
I'll give you one more chance for
pro or anti-slavery. A no comment.
Speaker 1: What I'll give you. Does
he know you can be against slavery and
still like guns? I mean, I don't know.
It's a very it's a I would not want to
leave any doubt my position on slavery.
Speaker 6: One more opportunity to say if
you're pro or anti-slavery, no honor, no comment.
All right. Well, there you have it. No comment
on the if you're in favor of slavery or not.
Speaker 1: It is. You know, it's a real gotcha
question. Are you for or against slavery now?
Let's be very honest with ourselves and each
other. We shouldn't be shocked that some of
the people with the Confederate flag gear
are pro-slavery. That's what the Confederacy was
fighting to preserve at the end of the day. You
know, I. I know that it's it's so common. It's
almost cliche that when you say to someone who
loves the Confederate flag paraphernalia, you say,
this stands for slavery. This stands for racism.
And so on. They go, No, no, no, no, no, no. I'm
against all those things. For me, it stands for
Heritage or, you know, whatever the case may be.
And maybe for some of them, that's plausibly true.
But at a certain point, the people that are
still using the Confederate paraphernalia,
some of them are going to be for slavery. And it
seems like the guys that the good liars may have
found such such a guy. Really disturbing stuff.
And again, we've talked about this overlap.
You know, the NRA claims to be a nonpartisan
organization. They're just about gun rights. It's
overwhelmingly Republicans. It's overwhelmingly
wrapped up with Christianity. It's overwhelmingly
wrapped up with conspiratorial Trumpism. And we
we saw literally the Christian pastor that Trump
brought up on the stage during his NRA speech
who said, I believe you're still the president,
you're still my president. Extremist right
wing Christian pastor and our member. So we've
got to admit and understand that that overlap
exists and how we deal with it. I don't know.